bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 26
février des vêtements trop grands pour
des enfants lui en courtois ont accepté
de poser pour le photographe julien
caloz dans des vêtements de leurs
parents une journée au cinéma en famille
les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr l'école
propose des séances en course au japon
l'occasion de découvrir pour la première
force ennuyeuse acquis 20 ans et une 20e
21e édition le festival jazz à tout
revient dès le 15 mars
quinze dates dans les yvelines et en
essonne porter les vêtements de ses
parents pour faire comme les grands on
l'a tous fait au moins une fois
et de se souvenir d'enfance julien
caidos ont fait une exposition
les clichés ont été réalisés au coeur au
coeur des écoles élémentaires de
guyancourt l'exposition est à découvrir
à l'hôtel de ville
après les mots le cliché julien caidos a
fait poser des centaines d'enfants
ce photographe professionnelle leur a
demandé de s'habiller avec un vêtement
d'adultes d'un de leurs parents c'était
une façon de parler du vêtement à
travers le prisme
de l'enfance est un prisme de
spontanéité de
on va dire quelque chose depuis naturel
dehors de mon travail artistique je suis
je suis photographe professionnel donc
je travaille autour du portrait d' pour
les indices et des institutions je fais
de la photographie de mode aussi j'ai
déjà fait des photographies d'enfants
pour des magazines et pour des
catalogues de vêtements donc c'est vrai
que c était un peu l'élément déclencheur
de
de cette idée julien caloz veux parler
de leurs projections dans l'âge adulte
la construction de leur identité 150
clichés d'enfants guyancourt toit de 6 à
10 ans réalisée dans des écoles de la
ville les enfants ils ont voilà c'est
spontanéité la dent en tout cas quand il
pose devant un objectif qui est quand
même quelque chose de plus facile à a
capté que qu'un adulte je voulais pas
non plus quelque chose de trop figée
donc c'est vrai que c'est un rendez vous
apprécié des saint cyriens la projection
de films d'animation japonais et ce
samedi 2 mars les yeux d'elsa propose
même d'en profiter
trois fois avec une job animations
charlotte assène bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes l'adjoint 13 pouces à abu
jeune public à saint cyr l'école on aime
donc les mangas on en est friand
absolument tout à fait on en est friand
d'un public qui est très habitué de ce
genre de cinéma d'ailleurs en octobre
dernier il y avait un autre événement
qui était organisée une journée
animations organisé deux concours avec
le service communication de la mairie
qui avait organisé une mangathèque à
disposition donc des jeunes lecteurs
mais aussi des plus des plus âgés ça
n'est pas que pour les enfants
non tout à fait on y reviendra mais
effectivement le qui dit jeune public
dit aussi bien sûr public familial pour
nous le cinéma ce partage est un art qui
se réfléchit et qui se réfléchit
ensemble donc absolument s'était aussi
créé deux concours avec la bibliothèque
de saint cyr l'école qui a organisé un
concours manga ou des jeunes et moins
jeunes se sont essayés à dessiner des
personnages de manga ce qui est loin
d'être évident absolument et la remise
des prix a eu lieu au cinéma
donc c'est aussi une volonté vraiment un
lien dans toute la ville exactement un
lien de la ville de mettre de se faire
répondre en fait les divers les divers
infrastructures culturelles et de tisser
des liens alors pour cette journée japan
et à sion qui une après midi
vous proposez donc trois films et on va
pouvoir découvrir ou redécouvrir parce
que certains les ont sans doute déjà vu
mirail ma petite soeur de ma mourut au
soda et marie et la flore de la sorcière
2-0 massa et au débat iasi est ce que ce
sont des classiques des films
d'animation lors la journée commencera à
14h par marie est la fleur de la
sorcière qui est un conte assez poétique
sur l'enfance mais on y reviendra aussi
alors c'est un classique plus ou moins
disons que c'est sorti très récemment en
2018 de mémoire c'est un classique dans
le sens où on assista à un imaginaire
foisonnant à des dessins qui sont
absolument somptueux et toujours cette
thématique de kate qui reprises
dans l'animation dans les films
d'animation et bien sûr dans l'animation
japonaise sur des bases on retrouve à
chaque fois qu'ils font la marque des
animations japonaises oui je crois on
nous propose toujours un voyage un
voyage qui est soit d'un lieu donné on
traverse quelque chose mais on traverse
aussi souvent un état d'esprit où sa
personnalité il est souvent très souvent
question de quête initiatique et c'est
le cas notamment du deuxième film qui
sera projeté
il s'agit donc de mirail ma petite soeur
réalisé par mamoru hosoda c'est son
dernier
alors il aborde des thèmes qui lui sont
particulièrement chères
l'idée de la famille le rapport à
l'autre à l'altérité
c'est un jeune garçon qui vit l'arrivée
de sa petite soeur qui peut chambouler
le famille un petit garçon génère par le
blé n'est en général
exactement il se retrouve des centres et
finalement de du modèle de la famille
comme il veut comme il le conserve comme
il le concevait pardon est effectivement
là encore c'est cet emprunt d'un
imaginaire absolument incroyable on
rentre carrément dans un monde magique
dans sa perception à lui alors il va y
avoir des des voyages dans le temps il
va aller à la rencontre de sa famille à
différents moments de leur vie pour et
bien pour comprendre ce qui lui arrive
pour mieux se construire aussi parce
qu'il est question bien souvent dans les
films d'animation de construction et de
grandir de grandir ce sont surtout des
histoires d'enfants parce que le choix
des films n'est pas anodin ça s'inscrit
dans le cadre du festival cinéma
télérama enfants a fait pour ça que vous
avez choisi cela alors télérama junior
absolument nous sommes partenaires enfin
le cinéma les yeux d'elsa et partenaires
cette année encore nous les avons
choisis parce qu'ils sont très
qualitatif
alors après le fait que des enfants
soient au coeur de ses films bien sûr
nous intéresse on voit aussi dans les
enfants des adultes en devenir et c'est
un peu le cas de l'exposition juste
avant donc comme quoi exactement un très
joli lien et il ya aussi une
particularité ce samedi une petite
pépite à découvrir ce que les cinéphiles
vont voir le château de cagliostro
ostrohove d'hayao miyazaki au nom très
connu
avec ses longues c'est tout premier est
alors la particularité je vous laisse
nous a donné alors effectivement le
château de cagliostro c'est sa première
sortie en france c'est un film qui est
sorti au japon évidemment en 1979 et qui
pour l'instant n'a jamais été montrée au
cinéma en france donc c'est un événement
auquel on est très content de participer
de concours avec les distributeurs
splendor film qui nous permettent
d'avoir accès à cette petite pépite
effectivement alors là il va être
question d' aventures de kate c'est très
rythmé
on se base sur les aventures d'arsène
lupin qui a parlé aux parents voire les
grands-parents l'arsène lupin des
besoins les enfants exactement validé
c'est aussi pour nous quand on organise
ce genre d'événements et de festivals de
s'inscrire vraiment dans une idée de
transmission
cette journée de animation elle est
vraiment là pour permettre de partager
un moment en famille ensemble et ça on y
tient beaucoup parce que le cinéma se
partage et pour revenir justement à
miyazaki et au château de cagliostro
c'est donc effectivement un film qui
n'est pas sorti en france alors on peut
se demander pourquoi on ya réfléchi un
peu et finalement en france dans les
années 80 peu de films d'animation
japonais japonaises étaient visibles
voire même pas du tout parce que le
public très simplement elle n'était pas
habitué à ce genre de cinéma pour vous
donner une idée on était plutôt dans des
retour vers le futur
l'aventuré intérieure on n'était pas
encore démontré qu'on avait mais moi je
vous propose qu'on regarde un petit
extrait pendant qu'il traîne depuis
quarante ans qu'ils pensent mais qui
était pas encore arrivé en france
et gars qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce lieu
manoir le seigneur les voluptueuses je
vais venir et vous voler votre fiancée à
très bientôt et de guerre de la
cambriole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la fille est dans le château
[Musique]
s'il compte vous découvre ici va vous
tuer retrouvez les et arrangez vous pour
qu'ils ne reviennent jamais j'avais
réduire en bouillie ce sale petit voleur
pour en connaître plus il faudra à venir
samedi
exactement mais dans de cette journée
c'est pas seulement des projections il
ya aussi un temps de médiation justement
j'imagine que vous revenez sur toutes
les notions développées dans les films
oui tout à fait en fait on est très
attaché à ménager ces temps là et ces
moments-là de médiation justement de des
changes avec le public de partage encore
une fois parce que parce qu'on aime
aussi beaucoup ce qu'on fait donc
absolument on va revenir sur pourquoi
pas de grandes thématiques alors moi je
conçois on appelle ça des conférences
mais ça n'est pas tout à fait le long
terme selon moi je conçois vraiment la
conférence comme plutôt un échange entre
le public et la salle cette
interactivité là on essaie d'y être le
plus possible en tout cas et un quiz
sera organisée également à la fin donc
de la projection de deux cagliostro du
château de calogero diffusé le dernier à
18h absolument voilà donc il faudra être
très attentifs merci charles a assimilé
la première projection marie est la
fleur de la sorcière débute ce samedi de
mars à 14 heures toutes les informations
se trouvent sur les bandeaux nous avait
vus lors de cet entretien
c'est aussi les vacances et ce début de
vacances a été studieux au théâtre de
saint quentin en yvelines avant sa venue
pour présenter aujourd'hui sauvage le
chorégraphe fabrice lambert dévoiler
quelques-uns de ses secrets de création
lors d'un week end de danse un sujet
réalisé avec aurélie rose
ils sont sur la grande scène pour un
cours amateurs et passionnés assisté ce
week-end un stage particulier leur
professeur fabrice lambert vient
échanger sur son travail partagé c'est
secret c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire le
plus souvent possible
ne rien garder partager transmettre et
je crois que c'est très important ce
travail là dans la dranse d'ouvrir à
cette générosité générosité c'est un
engagement envers l'autre et je pense
que le mouvement et et fondateur aussi
dans cet acte de transmettre un stage
adapté à tous pour entrer dans la
dernière création de la compagnie
aujourd'hui sauvage l'artiste qui
travaille le corps en mouvement et
chorégraphies l'espace lui aussi en
mouvement
[Musique]
voir un spectacle
autrement on voit je pense un spectacle
autrement pour ton il ya une certaine
manière participé ou quand on a goûté
des matières l'énergie la chorégraphie
de ce spectacle là c'est un autre oeil
s'est aiguisé un autre sensation
vis-à-vis du corps et de l'espace
deux jours de stage auquel a participé
une vingtaine de personnes j'ai déjà
participé à un précédent projet qu'avait
mené fabrice lambert avec le théâtre
nous resterons sur terre et je voulais
voir comment comment le travail évolue s
il y avait un lien avec ce qu'il avait
fait précédemment
et puis en lien avec la prochaine
création travail et le ressenti de son
corps jusqu'où on peut aller retrouver
l'archaïsme qui est en nous et qu'on
perd un peu avec une société super
moderne est trop tard un peu trop mangé
par la technologie
une restitution a eu lieu ce dimanche la
pièce professionnelle elle sera à voir
le 29 mars prochain une quinzaine de
rendez vous musicaux pour sa 21e édition
le festival jazz à toute heure veut être
toujours plus près des étoiles
michel beaucage marchands qui sont ces
étoiles cette année elles sont
nombreuses étoiles parce que le festival
c'est jazz mais pas que donc on a choisi
une galaxie d'artistes qui vont du jazz
avec toutes les tendances du jazz
jusqu'à la chanson française du reggae
pour la première fois dans le festival
et puis du fado ça sera aussi la
première fois dans le festival donc la
programmation elle est conçue comme une
playlist en fait on voudrait alors c'est
compliqué parce que personne ne va faire
tous les concerts du festival mais dans
l'idée en tout cas quand on les vit dans
l'ensemble le plus envie voilà ce n'est
le plus envie d'avoir comme on écoute
une playlist qu'on aime ou qu'on se
constitue soi même et qui passe un petit
peu par différents styles ben voilà
c'est ça qui est le guide pour la
programmation
alors le festival c'est du 15 mars au 14
avril en vallée de chevreuse la première
a lieu le 15 mars à 21h aux molières
avec nils petter molvaer excusez moi si
je le prononce mal un trompettiste
norvégien qui mêle lui aussi tous les
styles de jazz de la aux musiques
électroniques rock quand vous l'avez
découvert voilà déjà c'est une grosse
vedette du jazz de en fait de l'électro
jazz est là cette particularité que
j'aime beaucoup d'avoir un vrai son de
trompette parce que c'est un
trompettiste avec toutes les nuances de
la trompette acoustique et puis il fait
entrer des machines avec et des sons
particuliers qui donne cette couleur
électro c'est assez plat non comme comme
musique est vraiment il ya un côté
onirique on sait sans mener voilà c'est
une très très belle musique mais je
pense qu'on l'est
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très surprenant
tout à fait mais une très grosse
référence européenne
alors vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ça
dans votre festival mêle tous les styles
si pour permettre d'entrer peut-être
plus facilement dans le jazz qui le jazz
en lui-même peut parfois un peu rebuté
pour ses techniques de contrepoint de ou
pas du tout pc ou pas du tout au
contraire c'est pour montrer que le jazz
or en ont toutes les musiques
alors en fait on est très sûr le jazz
actuel nice peter molvaer avec le côté
électro jazz et puis et de l' influence
de la soul music et du hip hop qui sont
très importantes
on est sorti de la période free jazz il
reste quelques amateurs et quelques
artistes c'est pas du tout une critique
donc à chez nous c'est pas du tout le
style de jazz c'est un jazz qui randonue
mélodique c'est un jazz qui perd pas son
public en route qui devient et puis
voilà donc là on a deux très belles
artistes qui sont des jeunes artistes
qui sont king a cliqué qui est une
bâtisse polonaise et n'oublie hagard
siècle une saxophoniste anglaise qui
sont des jeunes artistes ont moins de 25
ans qui dirige déjà leur orchestre et
qui revendique une influences hip hop
importante dans leur musique est donc on
est dans cette couleur de la même
manière que hip hop l'état les samples
et des grands standards du jazz
il ya un retour dans l'autre sens et
c'est vraiment très belle musique
alors il ya des noms des artistes pardon
reconnu connu et une certaine juliette
je pense que celle qui parle le plus
peut être public au grand public
oui alors ça c'est les merveilles de la
chanson française et comme je l'aï dit
on et jazz mais pas que et dans ma liste
de le programmateur fantasmer il ya des
artistes et juliette en fait partie
comme on ait eu michel jonasz par
exemple
quelle il ya quelques années pourquoi
parce que juliette c'est à la fois une
très belle voix des textes vraiment et
un humour extraordinaire mais une très
belle poésie aussi des arrangements des
musiques qui sont magnifiques
donc c'est notre tête c'est notre tête
d'affiché cette année même si elle n'est
pas pur jazz
je vois qu'on vienne un petit peu sur
l'histoire de ce festival vous le créé
en 1999
quelle était la volonté première c'était
de le faire dans une zone géographique
stratégique de faire découvrir des
artistes qui se produisaient peu en
france
alors c'est un petit peu tout ça c'est
mon arrivée en vallée de chevreuse en
fait j'étais arrivé quelques années
auparavant
la mise en place du parc naturel
régional qui qui n'avait pas un volet au
tout début volet culturel très important
et une envie qui se passe des choses au
niveau culture sur un beau territoire
et puis ma rencontre avec andré
ceccarelli qu est le parrain du festival
et qui donc est qu'il est toujours et
qui joue tous les ans et qui est un l'un
des meilleurs batteurs du monde alors
lui une discographie est absolument
fabuleuse et voilà en parlant avec lui
moi je m'intéressais déjà la musique
j'ai organisé des concerts déjà donc
cette idée est partie cette rencontre de
cette rencontre est partie l'idée de
monter un festival de jazz qui nous
semblaient en plus ça bien adaptés à la
population et aux goûts du moment donc
c'est parti la subissent et ça s'est
enchaîné après assez facilement sur
grasse andré on a tout de suite pu avoir
des artistes utilisent en fait les porte
c'était une caution et ça le reste une
caution formidable il joue cette année
avec phil johnson c'est pour ceux qui
ont écouté le saïan supa crew ça parlera
beaucoup nous avons
on a pu voir dans l'émission quelques
mois précédent il était en résidence
dans une salle magnifique le territoire
donc voilà donc cette histoire là
c'était artistiquement c'était ça et
puis après comme souvent c'est une
histoire de bandes de copains donc mes
copains de l'époque il en reste beaucoup
encore dans les 120 bénévoles qui
organisent le festival maintenant voilà
on avait envie de s'amuser on a vu en
fait envie et c'est l'objet de
l'association de créer le lien social à
partir d'organisation d'événements
musicaux
parce qu'on avait envie de se retrouver
c'était une génération aussi donc
et puis on avait la chance de vivre dans
des villages où les gens avaient envie
de faire la fête et se rencontrer notre
public c'est un peu élargie maintenant
mais c'est quand même 60 70 % du
territoire saint quentin en yvelines a
des cheveux roses heures et vingt ans
après vous attirer toujours les artistes
qui viennent avec plaisir
alors il ya 20 ans j'avais cherché la
programmation maintenant c'est la
programmation qui vient me chercher je
reçois sincèrement plus de cinquante
propositions prochains jours mais là je
ne fais que des choix en ayant à la fois
de mixer des artistes très reconnue et
puis toujours des petites pépites les
découvertes où les artistes qu'on va
programmé juste avant qu'il devienne
très célèbre l'année dernière on avait
programmé la chanteuse kimble rose qui a
explosé tout de suite après le festival
même pendant le festival on en a eu
quelques-uns dans l'histoire du festival
ça ça fait très plaisir
merci michel beaucage marchands alors je
le rappelle vous êtes le président du
festival jazz à toute heure il débute le
15 mars prochain et pour retrouver
toutes les dates direction bien sûr le
site internet des haras à la création
numérique le château vendent des
rebelles connaît une nouvelle vie
longtemps abandonné le site a été
réhabilité par l'association usine
éphémère en lieux d'imagination
artistique
il est soutenu par la communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise le département
des yvelines et la ville de carrières
sous poissy plus de 200 artistes ont
déjà été accueillis par la structure le
château van der bilt est à carrières
sous poissy depuis 1885 2000 mètres
carrés de bâtiments williams qui semble
vanderbilt
l'homme d'affaires est éleveur de
chevaux américains achètent la propriété
en 1906 pour sa proximité à nos bars
légèrement surélevé pour voir
l'hippodrome aujourd'hui disparu il a
bâti je dirais son empire équestre ici
et fait donc de l'élevage de chevaux
sa spécialité pendant un peu plus d'une
quinzaine d'années ont des riches
propriétaires se sont succédé et à la
sortie de la guerre mondiale il ya un
premier abandon de ce lieu puis donc les
sablières moderne en fait ici et
exploite donc le sable les granulats on
ont fait leur siège social voilà ils
vont aussi exploiter les terres
attenantes au château le site connaît un
nouvel abandon dans les années 90
squatter puis rachetée par la
collectivité le site a connu une
réhabilitation par les usines éphémère
qui récupère des lieux en déshérence
depuis 1987
dans cette pièce préserver de quoi de
boiseries sont d'origine il ya quelques
graffitis bon voilà c'était retravailler
repeint pensée etc
et il ya eu en fait c'était assez rapide
et un an et demi de travaux donc c'est
vraiment rapide et un million deux je
crois de budget pour 2010 m car et c'est
sur un vaisseau prix du mètre carré
c'est pas énorme
le château van der wiel devient le
château éphémère géré par van der lab
fabrique sonore et numérique en novembre
2014 un lieu de création artistique avec
trois studios de répétition et un
d'enregistrement met à disposition un
atelier de travail on met à disposition
des outils donc ça peut être des
systèmes de sonorisation des lumières
des vidéo projecteurs évidemment le
soutien donc humain puisque voilà une
équipe au château on est six personnes
et de cette équipe
voilà on connecte l'artiste soit la
ville la cité soit évidemment à d'autres
acteurs culturels dont d'autres lieux
des endroits d'exposition de monstration
voilà tout un réseau professionnel qu'on
peut aussi à mettre en connexion avec un
artiste résident lieu de la bid oui de
la réflexion le fab lab voit naître de
nombreuses créations établi machines à
coudre et imprimantes 3d permettent de
faire naître les inspirations
artistiques
on fabrique des objets donc on peut
réaliser ses rêves
certaines venir voilà donc on va
prototype et certains objets on rend
accessible du coût des machines outils
ou des outils numériques au grand public
voilà on est dans une démarche de
vulgarisation de cette culture
scientifique de
toutes ces démarches artistes en herbe
ou public amateur le château éphémère
propose aussi des ateliers le 9 mars
prochain les familles pourront créer des
têtes d'animaux en volume une visite
sous le signe de la musique comme chaque
premier dimanche du mois le musée
d'archéologie nationale vous propose sa
visite musicale et son atelier sonore
envie de se faire une toile pour les
vacances deux médiathèques vous
accueille le nautilus à villepreux et
celles du canal à montigny le bretonneux
six dates vous sont proposés un
spectacle à vivre en famille aussi du
côté de la royale factory à versailles
le public par al aventure dans la jungle
indienne avec à nandy cette petite fille
espiègle ouvre la cage d'un tigre du
bengale
une fable musicale mêlant théâtre
musique et ombres chinoises
extraits
[Musique]
frère éléphants j'ai besoin de ton aide
ce qu'il veut manger alors que moi je
les fais sorti de sa cage qu'est ce que
tu trouves ça juste
[Musique]
cinq artistes amateurs ou confirmés tous
rassemblés au prisme à elancourt le 19
février c'était la deuxième édition du 7
8 humour animé par papy et julie chaises
une édition que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
retrouver sur notre antenne ce dimanche
3 mai à 21h et on regarde un extrait d'
astien bosch et farid rezki j'aimerais
qu'on se connecte tous ensemble du coup
à regarder la personne qu à votre droite
à la cire regardez-la la percée des
personnes à votre droite si vous êtes
mal assise beauduc ou regarder la
personne à votre gauche et gemma que
cette personne que vous la connaissiez
ou pas vous me donnez à trois le nombre
de l'animal à laquelle elle vous fait
penser toute honnêteté tout d'un bel
élan bienveillance un animal qui vous
vient à garder un truc qui fut le
premier qui vient réfléchissez pas
c'est maintenant un deux trois farid aux
besoins du micron bas en direct du
public
voilà c'est un méga complexe et acm à
gauche il y avait une personne affable
assez extraordinaire est-ce que vous
pouvez nous le refaire tu entends ça
d'elancourt d'huiles usagées fribourg
pardon je vois là johanna johanna fait
la vache très bien moi je t'avoue as
tiens je vais pas aller très loin
j'ai devant des gens qui ont mis tout
leur coeur regarde avec djs comme ça à l
apport et leurs corps aussi je vais leur
demander ses goûts madame franchement
c'était trop beau est ce que pour une
refaire l'animal que vous avez fait
qu'elle voulait me sauter dessus
c'était un cas l'animal unis si je vois
vous appelez comment geneviève bon sens
geneviève geneviève et johanna voilà les
deux villes c'est la fin de cette étude
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain
[Musique]